what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the sitdown today I have a special guest
on the channel welcome to the show zurka
thank you for having me Pearl it's your
second time now yeah yes and I want to
say your channel is the only based woman
channel on Earth I say that all the time
on Twitter too you give blackpilling
advice well it's not advice it's just
studies you read yeah well it's I don't
like the conclusions I come to sometimes
but I don't know I just can't like once
you see it you can't un see no as a
woman it's not that bad to read but if
you're a guy and you read this stuff
it's I'm
traumatized yeah um why don't you tell
them a little bit about your channel to
start right so I've been on the internet
for like four years but I was Perma
banned a lot on Twitch and then
eventually they they stopped bringing me
back like no one could help my channel
so I went on no jumper adam22 recently
this year I think in January and then I
popped off just you know speaking my
mind but yeah I'm like the first Muslim
Refugee Trump channel so people hated it
and they that's why I kept getting banss
and I was I was treated horrible and and
I got very political but now I still do
political debates but I I do a lot of
theological debates and now I'm a
Catholic Jesus gang and I debate about
that but most of my content will be
lifestyle content so just me living my
life winning women around nice cars
Lamborghinis and then people go oh I
want to be like that because man
everyone telling me get get in a suit
and tie and have wife and kids that's
that's going to turn the youth into
Christians no it's not happening it's
not when I went on uh fresh fit and
people saw my stuff when I just blew up
a few months ago it was a 1,400 emails I
checked emails and DMS and I would even
get the high schools of how how many of
the youth I converted into Jesus gang
and I was like holy [__] I'm better than
priests pastors and I'm battling Andrew
Tate like we talked about Andrew Tate
with his Bugatti and [__] he turns
everyone into a Muslim somehow so I'm
like oh [__] we need a badass on our
side yeah and so that's like my purpose
on Earth and I get rich doing it like
people love my [__] you know I always
say you know it's funny I always say I
TR I trust pastors that admit to
cheating
more because because I'm like at least
they're tell you what it
is
where where it's like the other ones
that they'll it'll come out and and I'm
I'm Catholic you know so they don't even
do that but I'm like you almost trust
the ones that admit to cheating more
because you know the other ones the
Affairs come out and everyone's like oh
my gosh yeah and from a red pill lens
you're like obviously and what did you
teach me cheating happens for most
married couples once yeah once that
means all those women that threw away
these marriages [__] up so bad because
they threw away when he became loyal he
cheated once and it's over he became
loyal for Life yeah I was like damn so
women are actually [__] yeah well
and only um they surveyed 5,000 men only
10% of men have had more than one sexual
partner in the past
year only 10% of men or admit to it
anyway oh wow which I don't know why a
guy would lie about you know you'd think
they would lie up only 33% of men admit
to having more than one sexual partner
in a year and men don't upgrade if they
[__] a Beyonce they just [__] her and go
back to the wife and kids yeah whereas
women always upgrade if they cheat once
it's
over all evil on Earth comes from women
bro no it does like all of it it started
off as a joke when I was saying this
until I started connecting dots and then
your studies and I'm like damn man when
there's like you could just break it
down like this single dad versus single
mom that is a scary different home to
grow up in if it's a single dad you're
safe if it's a single mom everyone in
the neighborhood is not safe no I think
evil happens when you mess up the order
of the world that's what I think
hierarchy right yeah yeah because it's
like whenever you take when it goes man
women children and you take out the man
it's like that's I mean that the serpent
went to Eve not Adam yeah and I'm not
even like I don't know how to put it I
don't you know what's funny I don't like
talking about Catholicism too much why
not and it's not yeah I know you'll see
if you I because I'll always say I'm a
Catholic but I feel like whenever I talk
about being a Catholic it's always like
a Catholic off like you're not Catholic
enough how often do you go to church
and if I don't measure up to like what
they say is like Catholic enough they're
like you're not a real Catholic and I'm
like look I don't it's where every time
I meet a real Catholic that lives the
life correct all I asked was I just
asked them this how many people have you
converted to Christ yeah and it's always
they it gets so quiet because they know
they're going to say zero and they know
the Entertainer is going to say
thousands and thousands and so I'm like
damn is let's look at it like this is
spreading the word the most important
part and it is if you ask Catholics it
is so technically even with my sinful
lifestyle I got to deal with that but
technically I am the strongest Catholic
on Earth right now because I'm spreading
the word the fastest there's not one TV
channel that does more numbers than me
and obviously you know I'm not a pure
guy but the fact that I can defend this
in debates shows I'm not like Andrew
Tate who's like a Muslim as a meme or
for an ethnic shield and to look cool if
you can defend this against Scholars and
[__] you know at least what I'm not
sitting in a room pretending to be like
a a you know Jesus gang you know I'm
actually reading this
stuff but yeah I don't that's I feel
like a phony because I'm not pure but
when I debate this stuff I realize every
Catholic I run into is a phony because
they can't defend this [__] at all if
you can't defend it plus you're not
spreading the word defending is myON
then absolutely my I'm not a real one I
know that's always where it goes since
you're putting women back in the kitchen
you're doing you know that's God's work
right yeah I mean I do the best I can
like every time you break a woman's
heart Pearl that's the Holy
Spirit even being a good Catholic yeah
well I don't know because they're like
did you go to church and I'm like I go
as much as I can but sometimes I miss I
don't know it scary to me how much of
these women's life lives would be fixed
if they took your advice like could you
imagine if you said to like those only
fans girls hey be a Virg till 25 now you
can choose billionaires and good-look
billionaires and then they'd be like
wait a minute I can make $100,000 on
only fans a h 100,000 is nothing yeah
you could choose bill you can hold a
Billionaire's credit card for life and
be happy with no [__] cuts on your
wrist and [__] but women attack you for
advice that can that would save their
life yeah well you know I came to this
conclusion that if I was a guy I would
throw out all the women over
25 now I know now I know I know this is
hypocritical I'm 26 but I've just done
so many shows and I'll talk to women
over the age of 25 and there's just no
saving them for the most part like
stubborn they're just too far gone in
the indoctrination I'm like the the
younger ones like you you can kind of
influence a little bit more you can
convince them little why around the
younger ones yeah yeah I mean okay let's
not let's not not young as you but
because they get it they're closer to
God yeah but um so I just feel like you
should at least give better advice to
the next people coming up if I was a guy
I would just throw out everyone over 25
but you know what's crazy is besides you
you say C like people say Candace Owens
but she's not that her message isn't
wrong at all she's not really telling
women the truth is she she's kind of
like a water down to me it's a liberal
to me Candace own is a liberal like if
you're not I know you're a liberal cuz
your words aren't making people rip
their hair out you know what I mean if
if you're a conservative that's not
triggering what are you what the [__]
are you saying you're saying nothing
that's offensive Candace if you're not
saying anything offensive how are you
how are you speaking truth to
establishment you're not yeah well
Candace Owens I just it really bothered
me how she did Crowder that really why
they had beef right well because what
happened was she um she she had a video
called Crowder is a monster where she
implied that and you know how women like
imply things but they don't say it and
and she implied that he was an abuser to
his wife yeah wow and I got like she is
a liberal I told you yeah and I'm just
like no come on stepen crowder really so
I don't know but I do like her I do like
Candace Owens I just I just didn't like
I'm saying you're alone in this field oh
yeah you are
alone and I don't believe these
conservatives if you can get up on a
Podium and speak and no one starts
throwing [__] at you you're saying
nothing of value right yeah that's why
I'm like like think about Ben goes to
school yeah he get him off the stage but
if zurka had to speak there would be
riots imagine when I start with we need
to put a sword to the woman's throat
imagine if I said some Catholic badass
[__] like that this is comedy I'm a
comedian it's my shield but yeah I don't
believe any of these people are actually
conservatives do you I don't [__] buy
it at
all well uh the problem is I I think
it's
gynocentric so do you know what
gynocentrism is yeah like a woman's
world viiew right yeah well it's like
basically women amazing men bad yeah and
we we just have a thousand even chivalry
is gynocentric like why are you you're
taking the Medieval Times from me I'm
like what the [__] that's exactly where
I want to take us but you're saying it's
still s yeah it's still but think about
it why are you they used to get on their
knee for kings and that would be the
natural order of the world where weaker
men submit to Stronger men but now
you're replacing it and putting a woman
on the top oh yeah even then they were
opposing yeah yeah so it's all
gynocentrism before like romantic love
is about a thousand years old and Men
enjoy sing that's why they don't no
matter which civilization they keep
doing it oh yeah I think men love to be
[__] yeah but usually other men will
kind of like beat it out of him who who
was the last real man is it genas Khan I
don't know that guy was a I don't know
that guy was a rapist I know Napoleon
was sing for a 31-year-old toothless
single mother I looked into that wasn't
just a poent so many generals were total
homeless writing letters and [__] yeah
it's so weird a warl lord kills a bunch
of people and then goes simps for some
toothless
[__] [__] I was like this is like a
holywood script like a comedy yeah yeah
so why how was your interview with Adam
22 or you guys friends what's that I
don't know what we are but we always
kick it you know yeah I don't know if
we're friends he tried to hit piece on
me but it backfired so hard wait what
some like porn star I yelled at M she
said like oh actually he's creepy but he
changed the word creepy to rapy and he
tried it on his show and I said I know
the bitch's name and I got it out of him
and I totally humiliated him and she
called on the show flirted with me and
totally exposed both of them but yeah I
was like I don't know if for friends
because friends don't just do random hit
people I've never done a hit piece on
Adam I could destroy him if I wanted to
go in on Adam it would be a massacre but
I like going on his troll so I I play
nice yeah no he called me
misogynistic oh yeah you guys beef ever
since he let his wife get [__] well no
okay because I wasn't even going to
comment on it but then I saw he was on a
show calling me misogynistic and I was
like [__] how am how am I the
misogynist when you're pimping out your
wife they are psychic distrust between
them forever now yeah he pimped her out
yeah you know and Adam knows I said this
to his face I was like she believes
she's going to get replaced so she did
the money deal I
mean they don't realize why it's a
controversy it's a controversy because
it's like telling the world we're not
going to make it so we're going to cash
out early but you have a kid together
yeah so but I guess you would see it as
okay because think about it men fail
marriages anyway so at least he got some
money out of it no satanic dollars I
wouldn't see it as okay I wouldn't no
because I don't I just think once you
have kids it's not supposed to be about
you yeah that's what my parents said I
was like how come when you guys were
arguing you never got a divorce and my
mom and dad were like CU we're not evil
we have kids you have to stay like at
least wait till they're 18 good Lord
even that even that traumatized them I
know one girl her her parents split up
when she was in college
19 and she went completely from straight
A to Total drunk [__] oh total drunk oh
it totally does hates her dad now oh
well that's why I just I started to
notice all evils from the mother because
men don't really complain to the kids so
when there's dysfunction it's typically
from the mother yeah that is a great way
to look at it men don't men don't start
crying to their children no so that's
why they start like they always you can
always see if it's Daddy Issues it's
really mommy issues typically and you
can hear it in their the child's voice
even adults who sound like women yeah
they are not sounding like women they're
sounding like their moms I mean you can
hear it like the way Destiny talks it's
very feminine like I can but he hates
his conservative
mom yeah yeah no but that's it's usually
picks up her energy right well it's
usually controlling especially for boys
I I think anyways because the order is
supposed to be at some point the like
the kid is supposed to surpass the mom
in the order of the world he becomes a
man right yeah 18 yeah yeah and
typically like you know she's still
controlling in the Bible at 18 the male
will have authority over his mom and
every woman in the neighborhood or in
the town man that's how you end all
crime right like I used to be so why do
Muslims do it this way actually covering
women up keeps them safe yeah like it
reduces crime by like 70% % yeah scary
it's like we want our eye candy but then
what they get molested over it is it
worth it like oh we get to see a hotc on
the street but crime goes up 70% against
women what the [__] so Muslims got that
part right well that's in the Bible too
to cover your hair and stuff like that
so yeah why Catholic like why did you
convert to
Catholicism well did you get did you do
First Holy Communion confession all that
stuff no I'm not even baptized yet I'm
waiting till Christmas okay but as I
think the the Catholic church is the
most powerful even though it's subverted
by Society of Jesus and the Jesuits and
all that stuff I talk about I think
that's the one force of good we can
morph to bring the Bible back into
schools because the Orthodox church and
the Protestant church are just weak
they're just they're like the Catholic
churches dogs really you think the
Orthodox Church is weak too I haven't
seen as much of woke [__] in Orthodox I
don't mean the Orthodox Christians
they're strong Christians I'm saying
they don't have any say in the world
yeah like at all like the Catholic
church has two dogs the Protestants and
the Orthodox and it's been like that
since the start really and people want
to debate this it's like go watch my
debates it's
like Catholic means Universal like
they've the whole world is run by Rome
people talk about Israel and stuff no
Rome Club of Rome runs the world every
all the money on Earth surrounds the
Vatican and it surrounds that fantasy
book well beautiful too yeah yeah I love
that too the artwork and I'm Albanian
Roman Catholic makes have you been there
have you been there yeah I have been in
the Vatican it's [__] awesome yeah it
was funny when I was um 18 we went to
Italy and I they they chase you out of
the the churches if you wear something
too [__] oh really yeah yeah so I had
something on like this and that's like a
big no no cuz it's like the spaghetti
straps they they literally would just
like I walked in and they were like get
out but it was awesome I was like that's
fine to me it's crazy how many pagan
gods are in the Vatican and it's like in
these underground Chambers we're not
allowed to see but any they're pagan
gods yeah they have they worship pagan
gods so it's like Catholicism as a whole
is the best Christians you could see
right but at the tippy top of the
pyramid
those are not they're not with Jesus
like the the pope and the Jesuits and
they they don't really believe in this
[__] have you seen after coid what they
did or what they say about LGBT now yeah
I saw that it's actually sad but if we
could change that Catholic power you
know it's a strong political power then
we have like a chance at at this [__] if
the Orthodox and Protestants will never
be able to do it you know and I think
Orthodox are the closest to the faith
right now because they're very
traditional they're like no you don't
see too many LGBT flags with them
Protestants are total homo and but I
still think Catholics touch the most
[__] Souls so it's like the best our
best
bet
so I'm just thinking so why like how did
you find Catholicism was it like were
you watching a stream or like what I was
like obsessed with God death and all
this stuff since 14 but I would remain
an atheist up until 24 years old then
when my best friend died I felt very
alone so I'm like do I want to live the
rest of my life as a [__] nihilist or
should I cling on to spirituality even
if it's just a fashion statement even if
it's like you know Andrew Tate's fashion
statement of Islam right now I'm like
[__] it whatever just keep my mind away
from that void do you think it's a
fashion statement for him well for his
is an ethic Shield but yeah for most
people like think of Andrew and Tristan
Tate if Tristan was a real Christian
wouldn't he try and convert Andrew he
doesn't even care he's like oh my
brother's a Muslim and I'm a Christian
it's this is not a [__] video game
we're talking about life and death Hell
or Heaven so like I can't have one phone
call with any of my family members
without me going from funny to trying to
convert them but they'll have phone
calls with every family member and
they'll never try and convert to Islam
or Christianity because they don't give
a [__] they don't even believe this [__]
but yeah so after my best friend's death
I was like let's try my first prayer and
it worked it was so vivid and accurate
and I was in the shower and I'm like do
I do this and stuff and but I wouldn't
say the name Jesus I couldn't say it but
I was just watching those Speakers
Corner Jesus debates I was always
rooting for Jesus but when I read the
Quran it made way more sense to me I was
like oh three wives because a man has a
high sex drive so I was more into the
Quran but you know I always wanted the
Christians to win the debate and then
after a year and a half of just you know
I'm I'm I don't want another prayer of
mine to come true like I already asked
for one to go viral right first I want
my family and friends healthy and safe
and then if you could just help me help
me I by the sweat of my brow just help
me with what I'm doing and it was to go
viral on YouTube because I didn't want
to work at nightclubs anymore and so I
tried praying and it was so accurate and
worked and I was having crazy visions of
me there's this is blonde next to me and
her face is blurry and then that was my
first collaboration it was like 9,000
viewers with some eirl I was like whoa
and I'd be in her room in shock that I'm
like well I had so many of these Visions
two weeks ago for a year I had had
Visions with that girl which is very
scary to me and I always had that was
when you went viral with her yeah yeah
and then I Tried reading the Bible I
said this is not for me this is not this
is fairy
tale but I was obsessed with Mar
Abramovic billionaires and why you know
Jay-Z and all of them do those kind of
black magic ceremonies or Super Bowl
ceremonies or all that yeah and I was
obsessed with basically the whole world
believes black magic is real but not
Jesus I was like that makes no sense if
they're like inverting a cross to
like spiritually charge a Sigil then
what the [__] is the cross it's got to
be some truth to it so I went and read
about you know I'm obsessed with power I
read all this freemasonic literature of
the people the the ruling class because
I was like whether they're brown Chinese
Jewish white they all have one thing in
common they don't go to a church they go
to this Temple called the Masonic lodge
and I'm like what do you study there and
then after I read all these Masonic
Books they're just reverse engineering
Christianity so just as soon as I finish
reading evil it just brought me back to
the cross I like okay I guess I'm with
Jesus so you basically wanted to know
how they got power and you basically I
was like why why are they doing art like
why Marina Abramovich Pearl did not get
a sponsorship from Microsoft for $150
million but Marina got one who's that
she does pig blood art you probably seen
her she just grabs Pig blood and Splats
it on a white wall and billionaires just
DM her I'm like how come Pearl doesn't
get a Microsoft Bill Gates sponsorship
but Marina abovich does this girl who
claims she's like a witch and does
Spirit cooking and then I kept looking
at these artists and I'm like how is
this garbage art being fun why can't I
get a $100 million sponsor how the [__]
is she doing it or a billionaire sponsor
like Microsoft and then it was always
that occult Sciences black magic occult
SC everywhere or the guy who invented
rocket technology again Ault Sciences he
says it's all from working with demons
and [__] in his books rocket technology
yeah the Jack Parsons I don't know who
that is when you look at Jack Parsons
he's doing weird sex magic rituals with
like nine other girls to have these
psychic Visions to be able to understand
rocket technology better and then when I
look into Tesla it always linked up with
that three six n all the numbers linked
to free Masonic numbers and then all of
this would go back to Egypt which is in
our dollar bill right the Eye of
Providence
uh on our on our dollar bill and I'm
like every single culture since ancient
times knows about occult science and
black magic and they all worship The
Serpent and Christianity talks about the
serpent is the tempter right and a lot
of people like Christian gnostics will
say the serpent is actually just the
penis tempting you to sin which is
there's a strong argument for that
because children don't kill themselves
teenagers do what's the difference from
a child and a teenager is they get
sexual and that's the difference that
when the penis starts talking they're
now oh my God I love that girl in high
school I'm going to kill myself for her
I'm going to drink bleach children never
do that because they're not sexual yeah
so a lot of people say it's the
Serpent's just the penis and then we go
back to the G in Freemasonry that's
generative principle like Sigman Freud
talked about all Sexual Energy
everything comes from Sexual Energy and
the more I read about this stuff they
would on certain zodiac alignment dates
this is is how Egyptians would do it
they would wait till like the clock
strikes at 8:00 p.m. on a certain date
to have that electric etheric orgasm
with their partner to manifest wealth so
they'll choose on a day like e because
eight is the money frequency and I was
like what the [__] all sex is
ritualistic that makes way more sense
than what I'm taught in high school
which is in high school they just say
sex is like a handshake and save it for
marriage but it's just no sex is like
this is why people get jealous and stab
each other for just like some one night
hoe is like there's it's like a soul tie
sex is like a soul tie so the more I
read this stuff all religion seemed like
garbage and it kept coming back to the
cross and I'm like holy [__] I still
remember so it has to be true because
the evil people essentially are they're
doing the opposite of Christianity yeah
okay they're negating it and what's
scary is their highest Authority
let's say Albert Pike he says I think
page 321 they don't actually reject
Christ they acknowledge he's God the
evil bad guys say he's God they just say
there's a second Authority say yin and
yang they try and make Jesus into a
5050 and so I'm like whoa even the most
evil people on Earth they still want to
be with Jesus like Hillary Clinton she's
evil but she still will say she won't
say Jesus is not real you know behind
closed doors she would never say that
but she'll just say like sometimes you
can use Jesus sometimes you can use
Lucifer well I was even thinking I
tweeted this the other day I was like
why because there's so much like
anti-white stuff now you know and I
don't really anti-white anti- straight
white meil is just attack on
Christianity they're they're masking it
it's just another attack on the cross
yeah um and the and I was thinking about
black pride or like you know because
you'd always have like those black
groups on campus at like um I can't
remember but like the black student
union and I was thinking about how you
couldn't have like a white student union
or white pride and I don't know I was
um and and then I started thinking about
how Pride's a sin anyway so why would
you want it yeah Oh you mean for like a
racial group well I was just thinking
about pride in general like even because
my first thought was like why can you do
black pride but not white pride but then
I was thinking like isn't that a sin
anyway Pride yeah well I'm a Catholic CU
unlike other religions at Philipino
Catholic sitting next to a white
Catholic they're on the same level
there's no skin difference but try and
say that to a Saudi and an African
Muslim the Saudi thinks he's so much
above oh really I don't I don't know
much about oh yeah if you've been around
every religion is very racial except
Catholicism where a Filipino Catholic
and a white Catholic they're pretty much
on the same level when they talk to God
but why I think uh why I Think Jesus
game should be represented and led by
white people is because they held the
cross closest to their heart they
defended it the longest so they should
be number one like they should like they
proved themselves throughout history
everyone else kind of like scattered
because at one point all four wings of
the earth were Christian so Chinese
really lost their way at one point they
say Chinese were Christian everyone so I
I didn't think that was true though I
thought there was like other religions
before that like and I don't know but um
like aren't there some like ancient like
caveman type stuff no I don't buy into
any of that I don't buy into dinosaurs I
don't buy into uh Lucy you know Lucy
like the first last or the last common
ancestor between ape and man she's named
Lucy cuz it's like another play on words
it's Lucifer I mean they lie to us about
so much stuff I don't really know but
evolution has been thoroughly debunked
like and when it came out everyone
laughed at Darwin think about all those
Geniuses laughing at him um the Bible is
closer to describing human nature and
the problem of evil and Temptation way
closer than Evolution that evolution is
so [__] stupid when you dig into it
just look at intermediary species
they don't exist so like when when a
[__] uh whale is turning into a land
mammal with legs there should be
millions and billions of bones in
between them of like oh yeah the legs
for there's none so it's like it's
actually hilarious because they're like
if you're seeing small adaptations over
time there should be so many different
uh variations and so evolution is just
[__] and another thing is like what
do they say say now they're like you you
share 90% DNA with a chimp but 70% DNA
with a banana like they just [__] with
you they tell us that scientists say
that [__] that a human and a banana are
very close I like what the [__] well but
you've seen what they've done you know
it's co science when they talk about
chimpanzees and humans it's the same
thing as Co science it's [__] well
and honestly the stuff they've done with
global warming has made me like not
trust any scientist ever because it
started from global cooling global
warming and then they're like [__] it
let's call it climate change they just
gave up they're like is it hotter or
colder the dumbest [__] or when they say
from carbon dating we found one
bubble and it's telling us that this
fossil is 68 million years old from a
[__] bubble yeah really wow does
anyone buy that [__] well even all the
stuff they teach us about like women
like that's what I know the most about
like women's suffrage history and they
lie they and and even the women's
studies departments and schools what
they'll do is they'll literally rewrite
history and they'll always say the same
thing like I know better than the people
at the time so like we know like and I
think that's the biggest mistake humans
make they always think that they're
smarter than the people a hundred years
ago and I think we're Dumber actually no
they say this is the best time to live
in right now don't no Revolution please
you are living in The Best Time Ever I'm
like what the highest depression and
despair and I'm born in the best time
because there's an iPhone on my hand
that's [__] [__] and I don't even
think technology makes humans that much
happier I think that's a big cope like
that's a huge lie imagine having a ton
ton of iPads and iPhones and no
girlfriend or wife the [__] are you
gonna do in this apartment yeah you know
I don't they they try and feed us that
technology made our lives great and [__]
no it didn't it actually made you like a
[__] rat rat in a wheel well and the
problem is now you don't adapt to
technology you get left behind in a way
like let's just say you're a kid and you
don't have social media you go to school
ever that's what everyone's talking
about yeah you're just like you know
what I mean that's why I always say I'm
like it doesn't matter how good your
parenting is in high school you lost
your kids to the state and the state is
whatever [__] parties is happening in
high school sad it's like you cannot
raise children in this environment it's
impossible well yeah you can't protect
them from the culture I have um a cousin
you know what's so funny I have this
Uncle he's an orthodox like um you know
how the Catholics switched a bunch of
stuff in like the
70s you know that okay you like they
used to not have female alter girls and
then they let female alter girls right
in the 1970s yeah 60 I don't remember
the exact Year my uncle goes to like one
of the churches in Latin like before
that yeah yeah yeah yeah and and so they
don't believe in any of like the changes
or whatever he homeschooled his children
and really he's like 5050 on if they're
liberal or conservative one of his um
Sons actually what one of his sons got
involved in like a thruple and moved to
like Oregon a three people couple and
these are homeschooled kids yeah you
know and I have it's so funny I have a
cousin that's my age she was like a
virgin on her wedding day got married
like she did everything right but it's
it's you know she's still 5050 on the
kids in the household and this is a guy
that Lit I thought he was so crazy when
I was a kid I swear and then I got older
and I'm like oh my God he was right it's
he was right about everything mainstream
media always wins the kids over they
always submit to that Kim Kardashian
[__] and stuff that's why I think I'm so
good because I'm like I'm like a rock
star bringing Christianity no one's ever
done that who's done that who who do you
know who's brought Christianity in like
a in an entertainment format I don't
know why Beyonce isn't you Christian
that's a Satanist that is Beyonce is a
evil human e Beyonce and Jay-Z are pure
evil
they work with the clintons yeah oh I
don't I don't know unless you're gonna
interview her she's no are you in talks
with her no I hate when I mention or if
I should talk a name and then you
somehow know them right like I remember
I was going to critique Kanye once and
my team said hey we're talking to Kanye
we're trying to get a zurka interview
with Kanye were you're gonna critique
Kanye I was gonna make some funny joke
and they're like you should ease up on
the jokes at least meet him first yeah
and that never happened so okay so what
are the like Masonic like cult things
that you're talking about I was right
Nick Fuentes Ryan Dawson all of them
were wrong and I like Nick you remember
our problems me and you were there was
me yell yeah yeah you were really
annoying that stream though we were
trying to have like a real conversation
you just kept screaming but check it out
I was right because they all laughed
when I said the final war will be
zionists and Muslims and then they had
this LGBT luciferian agenda and I this
is a I quote M this from Albert Pike and
I posted on Twitter when I got laughed
at by all these
intellectuals and now I thought it would
happen in a few years but now look
what's happening on TV I reposted the
tweet and everyone is bowing to my feet
that I was right I predicted this so
when Nick was studying who's the who's
the powerful Elite his prediction wasn't
that accurate um Ryan predictions
weren't accurate they were saying the
right stuff but there was no predictions
me 100% correct in my prediction way too
early I didn't know it start within this
month so when I retweeted I was like
holy [__] I'm the only one I'm the only
one I'm the only one studying the real
[__] if Nick and Dawson were studying
Freemasonry they would have been able to
predict it like me but they laughed it
off and said it's nothing it's stupid
okay so what what did you sorry explain
that more what you predict cuz at the
time I just didn't know what you were
talking I didn't I didn't do [__] the
pope of Freemasonry Albert Pike he's the
grand wizard pretty much the general he
wrote mes and Dogma this book I read and
um and he predicted to his letters to
someone he predicted three world wars
they were very accurate and the third
one he said will be between zionists and
Muslims but both will lose he said
because there'll be so much Bloodshed on
both sides and then they implement this
luciferian Utopia which what I think
that is is that Pride LGBT [__]
worldwide they're going to do but the
point I'm making is because Nick and
Dawson did not study Freemasonry they
didn't read his prediction they didn't
they said his prediction is just an old
man whatever I posted the prediction his
prediction and I was 100% correct so now
I think those two and everyone who
studies power and who rules us they
should start with the Freemasons because
now it's not just a club if they're
predicting stuff this accurate they're
more than a club right so I think of
Freemasons uh the Jesuits the liberal
Jesuits in the Vatican this is the
ruling class the top of the top of the
top of the top everyone laughed at me
who's laughing and they're the like
Satan worshippers yeah they're
luciferian so they have like the cult
splits into two leftand right hand path
of like luciferian or Satanist sun or
moon so luciferians run on emotion so
they have high anxiety and stuff they
have an obsession with stimulation so
those are kind of like think of your
meth heads but they enjoy doing evil in
in that intense way in in in a way where
it's like ritualistic and the satanists
enjoy evil in a chaotic way where it's
it's not that um it's not on this date
on they're more Carnage destroy
everything but it's the same [__]
group of evil right so it's kind of like
two think of two ruling families and
one's more evil than other but they're
both [__] disgusting okay and so the
two they predicted that well Pike
predicted it that the top authority of
Freemason okay so the think of and is
are they public or no oh it wasn't meant
for the public but we have these books
they're so hard to read and they're
veiled in allegory and stuff so no one
can actually decipher these books but
his notes were not meant to be public
and it or excuse me his letters and his
letters predicted the two world wars and
then that Islamic Zionist fin War you
called it the fin then what's what's
going to happen is that like the end of
times or something uh they just say that
they're going to implement a new system
because they say when there's enough
Bloodshed people will adopt they humans
need to adopt a religion when there's
too much blood and is that like the
Rockefellers are they part of
that yeah I mean that's like stuff Alex
Jones talks about but like I I just talk
about
uh the Jesuits in the Catholic church as
is the top of the pyramid and anything
linked to Freemasonry okay no cuz I know
I know that a lot of um I was just
talking to someone about this like their
thinking is they want to make like they
want to get rid of all the differences
so like the man and woman difference and
I don't I don't know if it's the
Rockefellers or some other big family
but I guess there're these big families
that are like liberal and they want to
get rid of the gender differences they
want to get rid of all the religion
differences they want to get rid of all
the races and just make everything into
one does this coincide with what you're
saying yeah like a communist superstate
where they abolish private property and
everyone's identical yeah yeah and it's
like a techn it's it's gonna come as a
as a gift to us be like here's your new
super City do you think they'll do you
think they'll
win yeah oh you do too everyone does
look look what they did with a cough
yeah they're winning hard so is there
any like hope or is it over that's why
I'm here that's why the CIA put me in
here a comedian I'm just a comedian but
no at the end of the day God wins so
it's like this is just the material
suffering world right yeah because like
look at it like this we're Give In
Paradise the feminine Eve says I want
more and bites God's punishment comes
down to hit her and
Adam and then God being the most
merciful since his only begotten son to
conquer death and save us from sin if
you think about it we're already saved
we're with Jesus but are we going to see
a lot of [__] [__] in this material
world from these kind of governments oh
yeah it's going to get
bad but I'm I'm optimistic as like I
don't I don't believe in Jesus as like a
profile picture like I I hear him you
hear
him it's like your conscience when you
do something good you hear feel the Holy
Spirit you know it's really interesting
because I think a lot about how
different of a time because how you're
30 29 29 29 so I'm 26 and I feel like an
internet kind of came when I was in high
school like smartphones or like when I
was in eth grade I got my first
smartphone it kind of got big when I was
in high school and I I think about how
the interactions between men and women
are so different um you know oh you mean
postd digital age like yeah like even I
was thinking about I was watching like
some like pictures and videos from like
the 20s and people are like you go out
to a club and people are like twirling
around like danc like it's very
different now I feel like men and women
I actually am going to predict that the
next generation of women is going to
have less sex than ever I actually I
think women are going to get less [__]
really yeah um I think people are going
to it's going to be like Japan where
people just stop talking to each other
Al together but the end they'll be
losing to robots yeah well I think I
think women will still be like aent but
I was looking so I went to this
um this like event thing and it was like
the first time I'd been out in like
forever and I was it was like there was
like a dance floor and no one was on it
right and all the men were like on one
side and all the women were on the other
and then there's a couple people talking
in the middle but I was thinking I'm
like it's not like anyone's going to
hook up after this you know cuz I was
like if if they do it'll be like maybe
those five over there I'm like I bet you
the next generation is just going to be
antisocial yeah awkward as [__] like you
see it in the Zoomers right now when
when I anytime I see like my nephews and
stuff I go whoa they're acting so weird
yeah I didn't act like that at that age
yeah so I actually I think you're going
to see like they just stopped talking to
each other because there's such a cost
now even for men to just like talk to
women like I just watched a video of a
guy that got he was um approaching women
for interviews and he was told he was
harassing women he wasn't even asking
for anything
sexual so it's like if he's harassing
women what am I
doing I should be locked up really he
just asked him a question and yeah well
he deserves it because these men will
not fight for that freedom to talk to
whoever right the freedom of thought and
speech because they'll be like oh well
I'm they start backtracking I didn't
think you'd get mad you had when you're
harassing me with your microphone you
have to say shut up [__] that's when
you dispel all of that her all of that
power goes away do you know how many
liberal feminists have left me alone
when when they when they used to say hey
what you're saying is verbal abuse I'd
say here's why it's not like Andrew Tay
and I'd explain why it's not verbal
abuse they'd be on my ass canceling me
and hurting my my paycheck for years the
second I switched the game plan and says
shut up [__] they just left me alone
they said this guy's not playing within
our it it they really want you to play
within their spellcasting of he just
like how you said who's a better
Catholic they do who's more politically
correct no you have to immediately or
say a slur right so sometimes I'll be
like this woman is a [__] immediately
all the feminists leave me alone because
they go he is not worth cancelling he is
unstable leave him alone he cannot be
cancelled because he's actively using
these words it's not like we caught him
saying it the PE evil cannot be
confronted it can only stab you in the
back so if if you feel any evil if a
woman says you're harassing me say shut
up [__] and that evil will go away even
like think about it you're getting the
same
consequences so whether you say shut up
[__] or not she's giving you the same
conse consequences your principal's
going to know the police will be called
whether you're rude or not the same evil
is happening to you so you might as well
test it out and for me it's working
great I've been left alone all feminists
gave up have you seen what I say on
Twitter everyone gave up on me they're
like he's a lost cause he's
just I think it I think it really I
think to be
right-wing you don't do what Andrew Tate
does where you're a sexist and Andrew
Tate goes actually here's why I'm not a
sexist and
this one time I yeah well I also think
to be rightwing is free speech so if
they say Zera you're a sexist you have
to say yes I am that's that's what yeah
I think Tate's trying to get out of
legal trouble though is my guess now
he's always like that he loves to argue
with women he's very feminine like that
where if you watch any of my Clips when
girls are attacking me yelling at me I
don't debate them I smile like their
children cuz it's literally Arthur schar
and every intellectual throughout
history said women never level up from a
child's mindset if you start arguing
with a woman you know what you're
actually psychically telling her we're
equals so if you start arguing with your
girlfriend you're saying argue with me
forever because you're my equal you're
making me
better but real men don't argue with
their girlfriends you you it's your way
or the highway I think there's some
Bible verse
about not using big words I don't know
what it is but I only sometimes I say
things and it's funny the people that
are like know the Bible like the back of
their hand will like back me you know
how like you'll say things and I'll find
you like a historical like fact to like
back you up you BL me more yeah yeah
sometimes like this happens with like
the Bible I call them like the Bible
people that just know it very well well
here's the thing and and I I have a like
a stick about how I I think I don't like
big words and I don't like over
complicating things and so people will
call me like one of my biggest
complaints is people think I'm dumb but
I just hate I literally hate big words
and I hate making things overly
complicated because it's like if you
can't explain it simply then I just
don't trust you and I think that's how
all these experts they like try to talk
over your heads and when you then you
get corny when they just go for big
words it's so corny that's why I say
women are dumb women are dumb yeah women
are there and you know obviously there's
exceptions but not really no there's
none imagine check this imagine three
billion women and not one of those let's
say there are three billion models not
one said if I keep my virginity I get a
billionaire hus how did three billion
get the science experiment wrong yeah
that is Terri three billion women got it
wrong no even me I was thinking about I
was like I spent my early 20s chasing a
volleyball contract that pays like zero
dollar I know what it is though it pays
it pays actually some but not a lot
women are so socially calibrated like
three billion men when I sit in a room I
go I need to be different from this room
that's kind of why I love being around
degenerate people I've always been
around Hell's Angels criminals because
then I would want to be closer to Jesus
because I don't want to be like these
[__] tattooed weirdos yeah and so
anytime I'm around degenerates I feel
like I'm glowing like I'm the good guy
because I want to be different all the
time I don't want to be like the room
which is bad cuz if I'm in a room with
good people I become the worst person
there you know I just have to do the
opposite I kind of relate to that yeah
but check it out women are so socially
calibrated they always have to fit in
the pack the three billion of them none
of them swam upstream and did the
opposite because they have to be like
each other they can't be different from
the crowd oh my god well it's it's my
God it's I mean it's hard like I mean I
get so much Flack like I get it's not
hard to be a woman for thousand
thousands of VI you guys have had it
good apparently yeah yeah you're right I
just mean like if you do you get so much
Flack and most women can't deal with it
yeah yeah but now now I realize
that if all if it's true about that what
is it the criminal 80% of them come from
a single mother not single parent single
mother
household damn lock up these moms I
would lock them all up and be like like
what the [__] you're bringing in that
much crime I think men should
automatically get custody okay I let's
go I like this I mean that's that's way
better than M but we're doing
both no um no because honestly zurka I
have a little bit of a nuanced opinion I
I don't think all women should have
children because there are some
crackhead moms that I just oh my God no
yeah but what if they have a husband oh
yeah no I I say the new generation of
women what do you mean they're on crack
no okay so there are women that I've met
on the show and like I've interviewed so
many chicks that they're it's like I'll
meet chicks and I'm like if you have
children they're gon to be [__]
degenerate crackheads yeah but God still
wants them to procreate so we're I'm I'm
still gonna fight for the like like
leave those crackhead moms alone they
just need a husband that's no crackhead
get a husband crackhead husband
crackhead yeah I don't know actually
what are we saying let the kids stay
with just the crackhead husband just the
dad that's how we fix the [__] kid
then the kids sell weed they don't sell
crack I don't know I've just met ah yeah
but that's Eugenics you're gonna tell
some families you can't have babies not
can't but some of them don't want to I I
have a feeling most women who have kids
didn't want their kids you know like it
was a whoops really yeah you think they
planned you think all these births you
see are like plannned I mean they can an
abort an abortion 80% of babies are
accidents that's what I think there's no
way people are planning kids people are
too
dumb am I wrong you can tell me I'm no I
think women are too so cira we can only
get pregnant like three days a month
holy [__] that's
real so if you got duped she duped you
yeah you can only like there's only like
three days a month chicks can get
pregnant we have Plan B we have birth
you can get an IUD that's like 99 three
days was it when are they I mean I I
think it's like maybe up to five but
really there's like three days that
you're really ovulating um it's like the
week after your period basically I
thought every girl I ever dated try to
get pregnant with me because I'm like oh
I'm a Chad but apparently even with
average guys they want to that's what
you're saying like they just all want to
have kids deep down no no no I'm say oh
so then they are accidents no I'm saying
they're not accident
accidents I'm saying that if you can
only get pregnant 3 days a month even if
you mess up you have plan B you have an
IUD you have like 40 forms of birth
control I really don't believe in female
accidental pregnancies even if I like
the chick and she tells me it was an
accident I just I I don't really believe
it I just don't all of them are liars
yeah that makes way more sense all you
[__] are liars and trapping a man for
I think I think the men may be accidents
but women no because here's the thing
like you don't see women accidentally
get pregnant by losers but I have a I
have a strong counterargument okay women
are stupid you really think they know
which day of the month it is like oh I
can get pregnant today they're too
stupid it's an accident I want they
still they still will get abortions like
I know someone I know someone that's
like um a good goodlooking guy but not
like he's pretty pretty unstable and
he's had like three women abort his kid
three yeah [__] do love killing baby
that's the one thing women are better at
than men is killing babies yeah even
before abortion they they did it in like
um uh like 1800s it was not uncommon
I've talked to some historians that say
15 to 20% of kids after birth were
killed even before abortion like every
time you look at female nature it's
always sneaky [__] something evil I
think I think it makes way more sense
that women are Liars when it comes to
Accidental
pregnancies yeah it's like what are we
more of liars or stupid it's tough but
is there a want they want the baby is
there I have a feeling there's a
subconscious want like they all want to
get pregnant yeah by the right
guy but like I I don't I don't think a
woman will accidentally get pregnant by
the wrong
guy I don't I really don't think it
happens and if it does she's taking a
plan be and getting an
abortion damn like think about it one
out of three women have had an abortion
that's why I say that means a lot of
Christian women oh yeah yeah they're
they're Christians until they're
not so okay so these Freemason so what
did you like learn from like the
Freemason stuff the biggest thing I
learned is that Jesus is real and all
the real evidence of Jesus is hidden in
the Vatican that's why we're given like
this hippie art and hippie Jesus well
just like the Bible says the tops of
like every institution especially now
for end times they're all going to be
subverted they're all going to be evil
and why did they give you Evolution
attack on the cross why did they give
you ancient aliens attack on the cross
why did they give you yeah I don't The
Big Bang Theory attack on the cross I
don't believe in aliens you don't
believe in The Big Bang Theory either do
you how you know an explosion means
chaos but this explosion put everything
into perfect order it's a [__] most
[__] intellectual design from no
designer this is the weirdest way to
look at the world so I don't understand
though you believe in Flat Earth right
yes so wouldn't people just fall off the
end well how can like what is the end
first of all I don't know it would be
Antarctica the Arctic Circle that's the
end that's the shoreline but wouldn't
there be like a a wall or something well
that the highest Shoreline on Earth is
the ice wall Antarctica so the water
would be this table and then it be this
would be the end okay and then you'd say
well what's that way like where's the
edge the only treaty never broken by 57
Nations is the Antarctic treaty you are
not allowed to explore there but the
first person to explore Antarctica
Admiral bird he said that there is more
land with it's not snow it's better
resources and minerals the size of North
America and he as he's talking behind
him there's a video there's footage on
YouTube Admiral bird as he's talking
he's talking in front of a flat Earth as
a monthl equidistant map the map that
airplane pilots use for autopilot they
don't use your dumbass marcer or your
[__] globe or none of that they use
our map and think about it this map
distorts continents why would an
autopilot system ever risk crashing a
plane with a map that just makes North
America a little smaller this one bigger
and there's an ice wall on this why do
they use there's one billion different
maps and they use the flat Earth as a
mthal equidistant map for autopilot
that's why a compass is a flat Earth
instrument it only points to North there
is no South Pole on a compass because
South here's magnetic north you
circumnavigate east to west that's how a
compass circumnavigates just like the
sun and then South would just be 180
degrees away from North so Southward so
that guy says there's like more land in
Antarctica yeah Admiral bird is there
anyone there according to him or it's
just empty well as soon as he they
discovered this it got militarized by 57
Nations and no one's allowed to go there
there's some Flat Earth there's some
flat earthers who took a boat and filmed
it going to Antarctica from the edge of
Australia and they're filming it and the
boat pulls up and says they're going to
shoot them down and it's all on YouTube
yeah a bunch of views and stuff and also
Flat Earth is the most Googled Topic in
Google history think of everything Nick
fent talks about think everything the
Crowder and all the doesn't even compare
well you know
what I kind of gauge people's like it's
weird I I when I ever I hear people
fight back really hard on an issue like
that's so stupid that's so stupid I I I
like think maybe there I'm not saying
I'm a flat AR thir I don't really know
at but but I'm but I'm more open to it
when people have this push back and
don't and like can't explore the idea
without how getting without having an
emotional reaction because I think
that's something programmed you know
from like a young age that's stupid
that's stupid well if that if the Earth
is not a sphere that that spins on the
axis of 66.6 another Freemason Galileo
number that if that something that
shatters your world viiew is by
definition a trauma so Flat Earth Earth
is traumatic to people that's why they
laugh uncontrollably or they cry or they
freak out but it drives anxiety into
into the human psyche right who is a
flatur Andrew Tate and Tristan Tate are
leaked flatur Nick Fuentes the all the
biggest Minds on the internet are all
admitted flat earthers and some will
have to admit it as a joke but then
there's leak footage of them defending
it and some will have to say this is not
a topic that they can talk about but
they they are flats but who's got all
the money in the intellectual dark web
that that donates to all these kind of
channels all the crypto fascists are
flat earthers and these guys have all
the crypto like all the biggest brain
conspiracy theorist are flat earthers
they don't believe in Hollow Earth they
don't believe in aliens they don't just
the Bible and Flat Earth and I mean
what's the alternative dinosaurs and
Aliens if the think about it Ancient
Aliens is
funded like it is Main
right so that should tell you it's fake
everything mainstream is fake yeah Co
aliens dinosaurs they wouldn't imagine
if they pumped all the Ancient Aliens
money into a Jesus movie they're not
allowed to do it it's illegal to make a
movie about Jesus they give us Passion
of the Christ which is garbage give us a
Sci-Fi budget for one Jesus if one verse
can turn someone into a Christian and
change their life imagine a movie like
Avatar but there it's illegal to do it
they are it's illegal yeah there's no
Jesus movie name a Jesus movie no no no
but the high budget right but I'm I'm
saying like that's not illegal though it
is
illegal why has nobody ever done it what
is there a law against it no no
Hollywood has to sign off oh I see so
they'll say no they'll veto kind of like
eyes wide shut my favorite movie that
exposes this kind of stuff and satanic
circles and stuff Eyes Wide Shut they
took out an hour of the child sacrifice
ritual scene of the movie but it's like
if you're Stanley Kubrick you're you
know you're let's say you're posting
your movie you're uploading on YouTube
who the [__] in Hollywood is saying wait
before you post we have to edit out an
hour there's always a gatekeeper and
that's why I'm saying the gatekeeper he
doesn't want to edit out the Jesus Parts
you're not allowed to make a movie on
Christ if one piece of scripture can
convert someone and totally say save
them from prison gangster life to good
Christian you know how powerful a high
budget Jesus movie would be where he
resurrects and they have the billion
dollar budget like avar but it's very
big no no they're not allowed to do it
that's why they gave us like whipping a
Jewish guy Passion of the Crim what the
[__] was that that's got to be the
lowest budget movie I've ever seen in my
life those a garbage so okay so why
would all these countries come together
and like hide Antarctica or
whatever well they all they all work for
the top of the pyramid right like oh so
that's like the Masonic people or yeah
yeah at the top it'll be anyone
subverting Christ but just ask yourself
why was in the so for the Soviet Union
why is 90% of Russian technology given
to them by the US is there really a cold
war why the [__] would you give your
enemy 99 90% of their technology that
they use today us gave them that
technology because they're the everyone
knows Russia's Us's [__] do you really
think Israel versus Palestine there not
a conflict Israel's huge palestine's
like a mosquito to them same with Russia
and us us is huge Russia is a mosquito
but they always give you this 5050
battle like USA vers
Afghanistan it's not [__] what are you
talking about it's a it's not a war of
attrition they they literally make they
they extend the length of of War it
doesn't mean afghanis are fighting
better it do do you really believe
afghanis help
Americans at Bay for like
decades nobody buys this [__] us is a
super Titan Afghanistan's a [__]
mosquito but they always tell us like oh
the Cold War Russia us no so you're
saying it's like a distraction yeah
there are there are nations and states
that compete with each other just like
how let's say 12 mafia families they'll
all be twisted and rape and murder each
other's wives so sometime they're all in
on the same project Co is the project or
whatever but then there'll be a Defector
that just starts stabbing the [__] out
of another family and killing them and
taking Ukraine for themselves so it's
like a mafia they they Shuffle the
pieces But ultimately they have the same
goal okay so they all came together and
decided to hide Antarctica but I'm just
like why would they do that the same
reason they hide why why do they give
you dinosaurs or aliens it's an attack
on the Bible because the first page
talks about the firmament so earth the
earth cannot so if it's round that's an
attack on the if the Earth is flat to
the regular scholar the Bible's
legitimacy goes up
90% that would change the fabric of
society immediately imagine if they said
NASA got it wrong but that ancient
scroll got it right everyone would panic
and say NASA's Force feeding us CGI
photos you know like you believe in the
Mars rover stuff or my favorite is
Jupiter you know how there's a storm on
Jupiter just Google Pagan God Jupiter
he's the storm God like you believe
there's a raging storm on Jupiter
because they linked it to the storm God
from either Greece or Rome but they it's
hilarious or or when you search up the
hexagon in Saturn the hex have you seen
that no anyways what I'm saying is all
these
planets that they talk about are linked
to those pagan gods they they're kind of
laughing at you they're like Pearl
believes there's a raging thunderstorm
in Jupiter who believed in a Raging
Thunder God is the ancient Greeks and
Romans like it's the same religion but
they repackaged it for so basically the
these groups you think have the secrets
of the world basically in a way yeah do
you think they started
America because um I read something
there was a guy who like predicted that
America and this was like three 400
years ago 100% George Washington
Freemason yeah yeah because when you
think about it America kind of messes up
the order of the world because I before
it used to be everyone it was like the
order of the world was God government
man woman child and I I've kind of gone
back and forth with thinking if I
believe God and the government should be
together um I question cuz I I wonder
sometimes if that's a way like you don't
want religious like persecution like
that sort of thing why not of course we
want that
H I don't know I would just think like
there's one first of all there's one
religion that's correct the rest well I
guess I guess I I think of it like this
like I I wouldn't as a Catholic I
wouldn't want to if I was in a Muslim
country not be able to practice like
being a Catholic you know everyone
thinks yeah but again that's a that's an
equality argument that Christ Christ and
Allah are the same yeah all religions
teach you things you can do do good
things and you take steps up towards God
but you don't know if you're saved
you're just taking steps you just take
many steps Christianity is the only
religion that says your leg is broken
you're not taking another step and Jesus
is coming down the steps to save you
just accept this is the only religion
that guarantees you're you're saved
every other religion is like good luck
they're not religions they're not trying
to save you they're they're political
systems most of them and Christianity is
the only one that is when when you
Stitch uh a Christian mindset to your
psyche you start understanding the world
like everything makes sense sin
everything the especially how ancestral
sin gets past if you if your dad was an
alcoholic you're an alcoholic see
science can talk all day about coid and
all that dumb [__] but that's sin you're
passing down sin really yeah like if
your dad's an alcoholic you have a high
chance that you will deal with that sin
so basically Christianity it explains
the world when science just says Big
Bang monkey and it's just like the
dumbest way to about or or or check this
out the greatest intellectuals
throughout history D Vinci all of them
came through a Christian era so could
you imagine step Crowder if he was born
in the 1700s like post like let's say
and they love to say Dark Ages Medieval
Times is the worst time to live and it
was just disgusting but they always
invert it they always invert the truth
so I think the medieval times was the
best time for everyone on Earth but they
hide that history in the Vatican that's
that's everyone everyone knows they
invert the truth why wouldn't they
invert history which is already warped
the timeline of history is so warped
well that's why I was actually thinking
the anti I've always been very much like
um free market like um free market is
the genery though and that's that's
actually what I realized is that because
it's like putting money at the top of
everything you incentivize the dollar no
matter what people are going to start
taking their clothes off for money so
the byproduct
the free market is degeneracy yeah and
that's when you really look at the
history of America it's like even in the
1600s we were leading in
divorce yeah like we had more divorces
in America um from the colonies which
had way less people um and we had I
think double the amount of divorces they
did damn yeah and that was just from the
colonies like the people in England like
the colonies would go back to England
and they couldn't believe the divorces
that were approved in America so this
idea a that America was like the super
Christian Nation isn't even true but it
was way more Christian than it is today
that's what I fight for yeah because
it's like yeah it was an old like it was
an old I think the smart people were
like the atheists at the time but the
regular Town folk the farmers believed
in Christ so I think that's how it was
you think that the you think they're all
they were yeah they were kind of like
from what you're calling the farmers
degenerate back I mean I mean compared
today to today they're Saints but so was
everyone yeah but like back then they
were the degenerates like and a lot of
the churches that were starred in
America had like roots that were kind of
shady um and I can't I I wish I better
prepared for that topic I could tell you
more about it but like I I just know a
lot of them had like weird Roots like
snake oil salesmen that sort of thing
just like those [__] Mormons are all
snake oil salesmen Joseph Smith was a
Freemason but now hold on how how where
would you wind the clock back to where
Chandy makes sense I I don't know that's
the I I question if there's ever like I
know there's a certain Pope at a certain
time that was beheading Freemasons that
has to be the peak of Christianity
that's what I think okay do you know
what I'm just a comedian I'm not talking
about this anymore okay um no I don't I
question sometimes like sometimes I
wonder if romanticizing the past or the
future is like from the devil because
you're not living in the present whoa
yeah because like so like this is a
common theme in history they always
romanticize the past you always think
your ex was better than they were that
friendship that time in your life like
and I almost think that's like evil in a
way I don't I haven't thought too much
through like the morality the morality
of thoughts 100% you're right that's a
mockery of who you're around right now
like to think about your past friend
past ex-girlfriend that's a mockery of
the friend sitting on your couch next to
you or your girlfriend think about it
that's e imagine they could hear your
thoughts they'd be heartbroken they'd be
like it's like if I'm around my best
friend and I'm thinking of this other
dude I used to party with and he'd be
like damn we're not as close as I
thought we were so you're right
romanticizing the past yeah there's so
much evil there like I I don't know I
just think every time period's gonna
have its like pros and cons what the
what what are the pros of this time
period
zero you can't even
women anymore I can't think of any but
I'm sure
there's I mean there's no plagues you
know oh you believe this stuff the plag
I don't buy you don't believe in the
plague I think it was just like Co they
[__] with you they [__] with you for
Co they [__] with you with the Bubonic
plague and throughout history like
there's so much lying through through
history like history is the most lie if
the news is fake imagine the history
books like all of History's fake how
arguing with someone about like this
historical event and they were they were
like oh she's ignorant she's ignorant
and I was just like here's point a why
you're wrong here's the the stat to back
it up point B Point C if you believe the
timeline of History find me one
technology that evolved the way we got
this kind of stuff like microphones cell
phones Stone ages for thousands of years
and then randomly boom we got computers
into like no nothing has there's no
technology that's ever evolved like that
where for thousands of years it's one
tool and then boom we're Top Dog it has
to be linear that's how technology
develops it has to be meaning that
timeline got a lot smaller now and the
top rabbis in Israel they get like the
Netanyahu and all those guys like bowed
to they all say the Earth is 6,000 years
old well all the money on Earth is
saying the Earth is 6,000 years old or
or am I going to listen list to a
government school kid who says dinosaurs
really so you think the Earth is 6,000
years old everyone in the Vatican every
top Rabbi and every top Saudi cleric all
the tops of power money royalty they all
say the Earth is 6,000 years old none of
them talk about dinosaurs they laugh at
you they don't if you talk about
dinosaurs or aliens with them they laugh
at you and uh they're into studying
astrology and like the correct way and
all that kind of stuff but just go it's
not even it's like public information go
look at the top Rabbi top cler Saudi
cleric or top anyone in Rome all of them
none of them [__] with Dinosaurs they
don't know what a Triceratops is it's
all garbage to them and these guys are
the the top dogs like this is who
Nations bow to which I used to think
it's the other way I used to think that
the religious institution bows to the
state no Netanyahu bows to the spiritual
leaders clearly they they know something
and I don't think it's bloodline like
Andrew Tate and all these guys say
bloodline bloodline Marina Abramovic got
a billionaire sponsorship just by
throwing some blood on a wall so clearly
you can attract royalty around you and
that that's why there's always been a
magician around a king because he can
bend the invisible forces of nature and
force it to luck luck his way so you
don't have to be royalty to be a [__]
world leader you can understand how to
bend the fabric of the cosmos you can
bend nature and and there's so many
Masonic books that talk about this like
that magic is real and it's thought
prayer and spellcasting and you do it in
a certain way on certain dates and
certain numbers will have frequencies so
if you want to become president You' be
intelligent to become a president on the
1 of the month because that one is that
leadership energy if you want to be a
lawful president do it on the date that
Donald Trump was born so everyone born
on the fourth has more Law and Order
type energy or if their numerology adds
up to four energy but this is really
what Egyptians were talking about or
everyone who says signs and symbols rule
the world in
masonry this is why they had
hieroglyphics this is why Carl Young
said myths dominate history you have to
study myths this is why Carl Young
stopped studying psychology and went to
talk to [__] witch doctors and
serpent worshippers he's upset
with what what symbols are to man and
it's like spell it's a type of
spellcasting but yeah all of this stuff
is hidden from us like everything you're
talk about dinosaurs aliens and stuff
this is all stupid [__] when they say
extraterrestrial when what do they mean
by extraterrestrial land meaning keep
voyaging out Southward so you you hit
Antarctica the highest Shoreline there's
extraterrestrial land that way that
we're locked out of that's what they're
talking about they're not talking about
up
there or
like if you watch all space footage is
fake it looks fake it looks fake as [__]
or how every rocket is launched from
Florida into the Bermuda Triangle and
they always Arch like this there's never
a rocket that goes straight up which is
[__] hilarious and they try and tell
us because it's a globe and it's
spinning but the a Saudi cleric said it
best he said if the Earth is truly in
motion which it's not it's a motionless
plane then fly a helicopter 10 hours
into the atmosphere and he should land
on a different country because there's a
24 hour rotation on Earth he says but
that helicopter will land on the same
spot every time because the Earth's not
moving and you can't say Corola effect
you can't say the atmosphere is pulling
the helicopter because then planes can't
get anywhere so you have to say a
helicopter floating for 10 hours must
land on a different country it has to
that's like it has to but it'll always
land where it took off from do you
believe in Atlantis yeah actually Plato
talked about it Plato said Atlantis is
real and it's funny there's stories that
say Atlantis fell because they gave
women power exp explain what Atlantis is
because um people might not know
basically what all these top rabbis
clerics and Priests and Bishops what
they all believe is Evolutions backwards
so they don't talk about this but we
were Geniuses with acoustic technology
we had vibration technology we had uh
like Tesla said we had infinite solar
energy from cosmic ether so even from
the Stars we could charge ourselves or
charge certain things so we went from
Geniuses Giants and tall and healthy to
Absolute monkeys so it's like utions
backwards we went from Geniuses to
whatever the [__] is out there right now
the dumbest people you'll ever see even
lawyers are stupid like even smart
people are stupid yeah and so we lost
all that technology but I don't think we
lost it I think they locked us up like
they put us in a grid and everyone
thinks like this Electric System is the
best we could come up with no there was
a car running on [__] water and
electricity like 100 years ago but they
kill them every time someone invents
like a car that runs on water he gets
killed so clearly there was better
systems and now we're in this Matrix
locked system where we you have to pay
taxes you have to do all this [__] and
there was at one point so much economic
Prosperity with America that everyone
was flying around the country but the
noble and ruling class didn't want to be
in airports with us commoners so that's
why they drove us into debt credit card
debt so it's like you guys are there we
we have our own thing and then now
there's private jets and all that but
yeah to they always want to separate the
middle from getting too close to the top
because if it's a little close we just
start slaughtering them and taking over
they all that's why they drive us into
debt or when we start doing good with
money they drive us what's Co drove
everyone back into dead it's like you're
back into the slave system so and I used
to wonder I'm like why does the
government not want people to work makes
no sense because the government's going
to get all that debt yeah it's [__]
genius or like I used to wonder why
would the elites destroy a nation that
they built because the nation has to beg
for money to rebuild and when they get
that money it's going to come in
interest they get the loan the interest
so if I destroy China China begs to be
rebuilt then zurka says okay here's the
money to be rebuilt but I'm charging you
interest that's why they ruling class
will D have two Nations fight each other
destroy each other then they both get
put in debt like it's the best system
they're so it's a hegelian dialect okay
do what do you think about um like so
you think the Earth is 4,000 years old
well they say 6,000 oh sorry 6,000 so
when do you think the Freemason people
like do you think that started with like
Lucifer well Freemason is like the stone
masons pretty much and they're from
Egypt that's why the Masons wear the
apron like the Egyptians but yeah Egypt
like the oldest tribe that understood
everything everything about the Sol
system like they understood about when
to have sex how to do it how to have
certain Visions so you manifest
correctly having sex and apparently sex
is like portals into a better world
right so if you have sex with certain
women who are been traumatized raped
stuff like that you're entering portals
of a much
less fortunate world where you have less
money you're in jail allegations against
you pretty much you're [__]
traumatized people the trauma follows
you and that all of that comes from that
sex magic and I didn't believe this
stuff until I saw Jack Parsons who
invented that rocket technology he was
talking about it it's like why would the
guy the rocket technology guy what the
[__] or like link one genius try and
find one genius throughout history
that's not linked to the cult Carl Young
linked to the cult Sigman Freud and
that's like one of the it's just the
hidden mysteries of Life pretty much is
like they understand how the universe
works and they can even shape it like
they can bend the fabric of the cosmos
give me an example
so and in Eyes Wide Shut in aliser
Crowley's book if you have sex with an
11-year-old boy of the highest
intelligence that's a type of sacrifice
it brings you immense fortune and all
this stuff he talks about with an 11
like girl no boy boy girls are not smart
it has to be a boy that's what that's
what it says and I was wondering why 11
and then I realized oh that's the
highest age before teenager so it's the
most innocent for the most intellect
that's what he's going for 11 right but
why the [__] is he considered the most
influential influential guy ever aliser
Crowley if he's talking about that and
Sex Magic and then everywhere you look
at the tops of powers they're all
perverted it's always about sex at the
top have you noticed why sex is like the
tool that the elites use to mobilize the
world there's certain stuff they do with
children and stuff it's always or like
every genius throughout history was a
sodomite Pythagoras Playdoh let's say
[__] sodomite that they got they they
had a boy lover oh wow yeah every single
genius president every single one of
them but that comes
from there's certain literature I've
read that says it awakens dormant powers
that if you have sex with a woman you're
not just shooting Soul you're shooting
intellect into her through the electric
it's like etheric pretty much it's like
the orgasm or Freemasons we'll say a
cold is not fluids through your nose
it's more etheric same with the sex
thing
so if you have sex with a boy he says
male on male way higher intelligence
than women that's why all Geniuses were
homeless because it's like they're
shooting intellect into each other and
Awakening devilish dormant Powers
through the highest level of perversion
towards God which if God's the most
clean the most holy what is the least
holy a
butthole especially if it's not a
pro-life making kids it's just two men
having sex and it's never two they don't
get married they have like parties where
it's like 30 of them [__] yeah but
the the least holy thing you can do is
sodomy apparently that's why in the
material world which is north west east
south As Above So Below the six the
number six of this material world for
that's for flat earthers for you you
don't know if you're nor thir because
you're a spinning on a ball or whatever
but this is how they explained it that
all these home homosexuals throughout
history why they had a psychic Advantage
is they have visions after their gay
experiences sometimes during their gay
experiences and it's same with straight
people that you have certain dreams
after sex that are kind of like you're
pretty much after sex entering a new
portal you go to bed you wake up in a
new world you're either getting rich
because you [__] that girl or you're
going to jail there's an
allegation right depending on what
happened but that all all manifestation
which you need a man to do women can't
do it alone that's what that's why it's
called manifestation all of it happens
through sex so if you those people who
win an award at a award show they lined
up the correct zodiac alignment dates
with their Partners this a lot of people
don't even know they're doing it they
just have an intuitive feeling that it's
a good partner so this partner will make
me successful they stay with them bang
they win but it's still very wrong
because using divination
to increase your fortune is still evil
you should be married you shouldn't be
right like I'm around three girls and
they what do they have in common is
they're all born on the 28th that's the
wealth number every billionaire Dana
White look through history who was born
on 28th and see what kind of energy they
brought or what they were given but you
know there's like exceptions right or
there's like a people that didn't have
the 28th right the exceptions is so low
in percentage that I don't care okay and
the exceptions always come with weird
traumas and [__] it's never a regular
life like a regular life 28 is very
wealthy but also you can check it out
like this what kind of human would have
thousands of years of Records but never
look to
see what the birthday actually means
like if you're born in a certain place
in a certain climate let's say in
January's climate at a certain place you
would say that's notable oh that's
science but why not just look in history
and see what does every number have in
common why do Freemasons hide this
knowledge why does everyone hide it it's
like
this it's so obvious that when for
example I went through prisoners go look
at the dates they're born on it lines up
with their numerological number that
gets R like Pythagoras says you reduce
it you add them up and then you reduce
the number and you find it or me for my
parents I said said okay if numerology
is real I know my mom will be a six very
home restrictive energy very bad for
business and I know my dad will be law
in order four and I said this stuff's
stupid and then I put their birthdays
together I added up my dad was a four my
mom was a six and I had anxiety so I'm
like holy anyone else if I did that with
it's just a coincidence but the who do
you know the most is your parents so you
can feel that number and I was like what
the [__]
but there are certain things that blows
me away like for that number Stuff JP
Morgan said millionaires do not study
astrology billionaires do what do they
mean by astrology they're looking at
dates again when they say astrology
they're saying dates birthdays that's
why like uh NATO was founded on Law and
Order fourth they want to be you know
Law and Order they um Chinese Olympics
before they became economic superpower
800 p.m on the 8th 2008 eight they got
to hit the money number 888 and I used
to think why do those billionaire fun
Chinese guys obsess over those lucky
numbers and stuff it's not lucky they're
looking throughout recorded history and
seeing how to get lucky so if they see
throughout recorded history everyone who
wears a black shirt was successful it's
worth trying but they they did the
trying and now they know it's like
proven science and now to me it's so
weird there's
like why have I never thought of looking
what every birthday has in common like
wouldn't there be a different
temperament for men born on this exact
January and stuff why has think about
recorded history you could control the
world if you have the first hundred
years you don't have that much info
thousands of years of birthdays now
you've got science you know what the
[__] going on but I'm very new to this
stuff you know and it's kind of horrible
because I'll be sitting on a date with a
girl and I can't hear anything she's
saying I was like just give me the
birthday I need to know what the numb
what are what are the best birthdays for
like your birthday well you'll only ever
see me on camera with eights or 28s if a
if if girls don't add up to that number
I'll never be around
them right it's not that I'm [__]
them it's that if I'm gonna be drinking
doing dumb [__] with dumb hoes at least
give me some lucky dumb hoes does that
mean like none of our stuff will go
viral because I I'm a four I think no
there's four Myron's a four okay Donald
Trump is a four he's the most viral but
I thought you just said eights and 28s
like are the only ones you you can make
money with so I'm saying wouldn't that
mean this like wouldn't go viral or do
well because I'm a four not an eight or
a 28 well no that it just it just means
the magnitudes more but success you can
have with any numbers right there's if
there's Soul Synergy it doesn't really
matter like for example you could post
this on the eth that's like a money day
okay so and you can actually look at
commercials and see see when they're
first posted or like you know how Super
Bowl will pick a date start noticing
this stuff and it's actually crazy but
sometimes you won't notice it like for
example there'll always be a four and a
four in these commercials but that's an
eight what is soul Synergy like between
two people who like each other that can
overcome a gold digger let's say like
there's as evil as women are there's
still a spark that she'll leave the
millionaire for a criminal there's still
some of those women yeah that would be
perfect Synergy right like that she
connects with with a Criminal soul I
used to have that why I always thought
so highly of
women is because of how they treated me
I was like if I got locked up they'd be
around me they would never cheat I've
never been cheated on not that I know of
but because I was watching in nightclubs
everyone else get cheated on my anxiety
would build and I'd be like I don't care
if they treat me like a king for the
rest my life if 99% of my neighborhood's
being cheated on these are [__] like I
don't care it's like the dragon only is
nice to me still evil it's still biting
everyone so it's like I that's how I see
it and then when I started speaking it
on on
microphones women never deny this stuff
they kind of smile like here's when I
knew women are evil when I met women who
their top donators killed themselves and
they tell me the story behind closed
doors and there's a bubbly excitement
when they tell the story like John he
loved me so much he had photos of me he
it's sad but he killed himself and the
way they tell this is like I've never
seen a happier human it's like imagine a
man the my top donator my top donator
killing themselves imagine how a man
would talk about it they they talk about
it serious the jokes would come years
later it wouldn't be like women why
there so much funny about a man killing
themselves to a woman is because they
feel unsafe he's not strong he killed
himself I hate him anything that makes
them feel unsafe right it's like when
they're around me they're very giggly
because they feel safe but as soon as my
buddy comes at the carnival and I have
to go pee they're talking about let's
get out of here they they're asking what
do you even do for a living to my best
friend because he's not an authority
they don't feel safe around him they
start questioning him do you have money
do you have this but around me oh okay
this guy's like the man right this guy
will punch a woman he's for real I'm
kidding but that's what I noticed all
evil comes from a woman looking around
and saying holy [__] I don't feel safe
laugh at the man who killed himself
attack all men ask all men what they do
for a living cheat on Old Men it always
comes from they're not taking care of me
or my kids destroy old they just flip
that's why Financial insecurity is the
number one reason women divorce men
right but think about about where that
comes from right that fear how do you
stop liking a husband because of money
that makes no sense but it's because
she's like I'm unsafe and he's the
problem am I wrong or they they when
they feel unsafe they turn
evil um I I don't know if I buy that
yeah the Pearl answer is they're evil
regardless well to me it's like they
they like okay trying to throw them a
bone trying you're evil cuz of this
she's like no you're born
evil I don't know because the way I see
it is
like we choose instability how many
women pick they they leave because of
financial instability quote unquote but
they pick two rents instead of one what
do you mean by that they they pick
robbery they they they say he can't
provide for me then leave and take his
money so they pick it's not actually
Financial instability
so what is it I don't know evil damn now
think about it like okay if me and you
were together and I say oh you're too
financially unstable and leave then I
take child support from you now we have
two rents two food bills like you're not
going to become more financially stable
I'm just robbing I didn't say they're
logical I think I think that's the
reason they're
leaving I don't know really I don't know
maybe you might be right there's always
the idea that there's another man saving
her true true but but and it doesn't
really no no bro that idea that there's
another man billionaire come to save
them is in every woman's mind that's why
they're all single I can do better I can
do better here comes the billionaire
[__] you're 40 you never did better the
[__] I there should be a system where
couples go in and women are told don't
[__] it up with this guy it's not going
to get better for there should be like a
used to be
Dads Dads Suck now dad's I talk to Dad
you know what's the craziest thing about
dads there's this one I love to death
he's in my chat he's like 45 years old
his daughter is an influencer he watches
everything that comes out of my mouth he
says to her boyfriend you are not
marrying my influencer daughter zurka is
marrying her in front of his face and
I'm like I thought it was a joke and I'm
like Bro you've seen the stuff I said
say why the hell would you want me to
marry your daughter that's how much dads
hate Sims that they'll throw their
[__] daughters to me what am I going
to do Coke and disappear I'll go for
cigarettes for a thousand years I'll
never come back the men hate simps that
much that they'll throw them to [__]
even criminals I think I don't think so
I think I think men's set up every dad I
meet tries to set me up with their
daughter I've never met a dad that
didn't try sent me up with their
daughter I know I see I see I think most
dads would pick Sims really I think they
would yeah no I meet dads and yeah cu
the ones that are following you already
like you is the red pill you're saying
they're like that I think most dads are
blue pill yeah I think red pill dads are
blue pill I think there's a reason why
women don't pick the dad or the guy that
their dads would pick I'll never trust a
man that never pushed a woman like men
who raised their I've never pushed the
you've never pushed a woman I'll will
never trust a man I'm not saying hit
them but if you went your whole life and
you never pushed the woman that's you
are the biggest [__] on Earth women
throw drinks on you you're not going to
push them just push them not down the
stairs just push him a little bit that's
not domestic abuse is it I'm kidding I'm
a
comedian so I wasn't it you who said
hitting a woman saves millions of them
because it sets the [__] example oh
yeah yeah I think I'm saving lives I
think no I think if women were afraid of
getting hit back I think a lot less
women would do it but they just know
they don't leave their domestic abusers
yeah I know why because they feel safe
beat up by that women are more abusive
and violent than men yeah you you
convinced me on that 100% yeah because I
mean real violence is who kills the
innocent women do that far more than men
babies oh yeah and elderly even after
they're born like infant like babies
getting killed within the first 24 hours
it's so rare when it's done by a man
it's like unheard of like not even
recorded in history I wouldn't say that
I'm just I know when it happens it's
like it's crazy like it barely ever
happens um wait so this is why they
suppressed female sexuality cuz it's
like a tornado yeah women are that evil
but even you're saying when they're
supressed they're evil no so imagine
when they're liberated no I'm saying
when we're liberated we're evil because
think about it like Ted Bundy had women
writing him love letters in prison oh
yeah that's how women pick I used to see
that with my drug dealer friends I'm
like women can date criminals in prison
men will never date a woman in prison
you'll never really I mean I mean Casey
Anthony got remarried I don't see that
happen often women love criminals women
love evil yeah much more than it's not
the same you're correct it's not the
same I remember when I first noticed a
man will never pick a woman for being a
criminal it's cuz she's a hot I remember
when I first said to myself this girl
sitting next to me that I'm dating will
never cheat on me is the first time I
realized I at that point in my life I
hated everyone even the [__] waiter I
was so violent but she was cool in my
bush she my girlfriend that's when I
realized I'm like whoa if you are
actually a tyrant and evil and you hate
Rob everyone steal pull knives on people
but you're on her team she's cool she's
it's like they're down for a psychopath
as long as it's on their team even if
they even if I punch her a few times
they go I'm still safe from the other
things in the world because this guy's
violent so it's like when I say women
don't leave domestic abusers is because
there's more abuse in the world that
they're being shielded from by the
abuser but they're getting punched too
you get it so it's like he'll punch them
but they'll be like Oh I'm safe here but
if some Criminal walks in the house the
domestic abused boyfriend is going to
murder that criminal walking in the
house what do you what do you think
about success do you think success comes
more from the devil or from
God uh it depends look at white people
and look at the tribe I'm not going to
mention I don't want to get anyone hurt
here success with peace of mind is
always with God hyper billionaire
success with anxiety depression anxious
you know those billionaires always
always trying to cheat on their wives
always trying to kill someone to stay
top dog like Mafia mafia's Mafia always
looks behind their shoulder success
without Peace of Mind always from the
devil every single time but success with
peace of mind so you have a big Ranch
and you're just a rich farmer with a
nice wife and kids that's clearly from
God it's like two there's only two
energies like um love and fear every
emotion stems from these according to
masonry h give me an example of
both um a millionaire no no like give me
a real a like give me real people okay I
want to see it all right let's
try why am I going a billionaire hold on
um wow this is tough because I'm
thinking of iconic names they're always
with the devil every single one of them
wow there's a lot of evil here
do you know why it's hard to for me to
think of someone who is with God is
they're boring they're not on TV I'm
think of all the TV names that yeah so
this is tough
um holy [__] you stumped me do you think
your success is from God or the devil
100% from God because of the topic that
demonetize me why do you think I brought
that topic to 100,000 viewers on Rumble
cuz I panicked was like if I'm saying
whatever I want to say I'm the first
person in 20 years of the digital age to
say this disgusting any slur and still
[__] make a [__] ton of money success
Fame Friends Network from it no one has
ever gone through this success portal
I'm staying up at night I'm like there's
no way I'm with God if my life's this
overpowered so I'm like let's put it to
the test the most nuclear illegal topic
which is you know which one and I
brought it to rumble obviously it
demonetized me and I lost a bunch lost
my Discord I lost so much but that was
the first time I said I have my life
still put together even though it's
damaged financially damaged all that
stuff
happened I kept saying the truth and my
life kept getting better but I would be
in rooms where it's like hey don't say
that you can have $2 million by the end
of the year you know I was was in those
rooms and I'm like well I have to say
that or else my chat were the same ones
we're we're we're going to call me a
phony I'll feel like a phony so I kept
being put into like am I trading morals
for
money every single time I would be made
fun of you could have so much more money
if you just toned it down a bit no [__]
no because I have to be politically
incorrect to bring the Bible into the
schools you know how Politically
Incorrect the Bible is it says the LGBT
are [__] MH right like that's very
Politically Incorrect book so I have to
remain like this I 100% believe I'm with
God but why that's not a
flex you could be with God for 40 years
and go back to the devil so that's why
idol worship is wrong never idol worship
someone because they could be perfect
for 40 years you could watch all their
content for 40 years and they could
snaap into the devil right right that's
why worship so dangerous so when I say
I'm with God I'm really saying right now
there's going to be huge contracts where
hey talk about Jesus less and then years
from now people will be noticing Y zerka
is even richer but he hasn't had one
theological debate in a year now wa
that's a demoralization Alchemy where
I'm switching philosophically what's
happening in my brain because because
they're always probably fighting for
your soul yeah I think it's a constant
tug yeah but it's like just life is so
simple Soul nourishment that's all you
have to do and then Sweat by the brow
like the Bible says so it's Soul
nourishment and career so for me it'll
be Bible content or for someone else
it'll be Bible fixing bikes or whatever
the [__] their career is like to be a
master in that trade or Bible farming
but that's all you have to do now when
you just say when you take out the
spiritual component and just do farming
you can make giant Farms me mechanical
farms and be billionaire if you're just
in the material world with no soul
nourishment you have no peace of mind
you're always fighting for top spot
you're listen imagine if I couldn't say
slurs and I had a Ferrari think of if I
went to that that Fashion Week wanted me
to do some gay [__] for a big money
imagine I did a bit b a gay photo shoots
right in my Ferrari could I ever enjoy
that Ferrari again no cuz I didn't do
the Soul nourishment part I just did the
M material and career part so you have
to do Soul nourishment and it's so
simple Carl Young talks about it like
this the stuff you suppress you
eventually
explode by suppressing it so if you've
seen a lot of dads will suppress a
passion for 10 20 years and then all of
a sudden they have a midlife crisis
about boats oh I need a boat they start
but they're suppressing it they're
supposed to feed that passion because
the boat's about freedom and being
emotion from God or the devil most 99%
of passion is from the devil 99 really
all mental all emotions from the devil
God it's interesting because I I think
I'm a passionate person you think that's
from the devil I'm a passionate person
too I think it's devilish yeah all
successful people all successful people
are passionate and passion is there's
two paths passion and compassion okay
now you see what I'm saying right no I
don't compassion will be family passion
will be career that's why career
oriented people aren't really family
people they don't or like my nature I'm
not a family person in in a way where
when I live with a girlfriend she's not
allowed to come to half of my house so
for half of the apartment she's not
allowed to even walk around there
because I'm super loner then I have
surges of mania where I want to be
around her and you think that's all from
the devil oh yeah because what am I
doing when I'm alone career career
career totally destroying her life
because women can't be alone so that's
why women are like oh my God you're the
biggest phony I've ever dated because
they say they try and get me like this
go date zurka he's nothing of what he is
on camera he never
speaks yeah cuz you're literally a
[__] woman I'm in front of a camera
in front of like an audience I get
graded on this performance I make money
there's like a whole I'm never GNA put
this much energy talking to a [__]
dog brained woman you know what I mean
yeah and it never benefited me I was
like if 90% of human communication is
nonverbal why are why is anyone arguing
with their girlfriend or wife yeah what
is argu arguing is getting you closer to
a divorce so like never talk to them no
it's so interesting though so how would
you like overcome that if passion's from
the devil well that's why I do Soul
nourishment I'll always go back to the
Bible that's why I try to convince you
that your final political phase will be
a spiritual one or else you'll go crazy
czy who do you know in his think of all
those famous YouTubers prank channels
they make millions of dollars but just
like Disney stars they destroy their
lives the only ones who make it are the
ones that mature and become spiritual
can I tell you just like a weird thought
I have I I find
it and I don't know how to describe this
this is going to be a weird like it's
fine thoughts we all have what it's a
devilish thought right no I don't know
if it's a devilish thought may maybe it
is you tell don't act on it no wait let
me let me say don't be a lesbian let me
let me say it sometimes I I feel like
people make their faith into a brand yes
and it's not really I don't see it in
you but I see it a lot in tradcons and I
don't I don't know how to describe it
but I've always felt like my faith is
more of like a private thing like I've
just always felt like that and then it's
weird when you become public because
everyone like wants you to talk about it
all the time you and I don't you're 100%
right I and I don't know how to like I I
guess balance the two because I also
don't think like I think there's people
that are way better with religion than
me I think there's people that pray way
more than like I don't look at myself as
like they're not first of all like
you're saying that people use religion
as a fashion statement like in those
Twitter circles even even
um it's cringe and I want to I want to
we might just say some names they're
cornballs speak it out okay um even even
sneo sometime like I just don't really
believe the like Islam I just don't
really believe it I don't see it in him
I I just like that he stopped drinking
because of it yeah part cool yeah um and
even Tate I question it a little bit and
I like I like them and I see this in the
tradcons too um and I even and
especially the women in the tradcons
like they're very controlling they're
they're all and this isn't I hate saying
this because I don't want to insult
anybody but I I don't know how to
describe it it's just a feeling and God
only knows you know we feel a bunch of
things but I I don't like it when people
like I almost feel like it's using God's
name in vain in a way um but then
they'll kind of come back at me and be
like look at this verse you're supposed
to tell everyone so I don't know how to
balance the two well only one there's
only one verse that matters as if you're
with Christ is to spread the word so
you're failing because you don't want to
spread it it's more personal for you
it's not personal because God gave you a
platform you're huge and famous you
better spread it and is it contributing
to goodness which pyramids to God right
all goodness pyramids to God you got to
ask yourself that to all those people
you mentioned and I think everyone on
Earth that cannot debate their faith is
burning in hell they're I'm not saying
they're going to hell I would never say
that I don't the Catholics don't even
believe that we should judge you know
who goes to heaven and hell
but I think if you cannot debate your
religion you don't believe it if you
cannot debate you you're telling me you
debate about every you debate about
which chocolate bar is better you debate
about everything but you're going to go
hundred years in your life not debating
the god question that's why every single
YouTube channel that's Christian none of
them debate they just go hi um today me
and my wife went to Sunday mass and I I
don't give a [__] if you went to mask
convert or debate and convert people
through debating tell I'll tell you I'll
tell you why I decided I was Catholic um
because I was raised it and um Bas yeah
well partially and I had I when I was
like 21 I was living in Milwaukee by
myself and I didn't really have any like
friends was alone and and really
Milwaukee you the [__] what Milwaukee
yeah I that um uh it's a Wiscon
yeah yeah yeah that 7 no I I didn't I
didn't go to Milwaukee University this
was this was after college I graduated
and I went to work as sales job and I
basically wrote on a board all the
religions so I wrote like Islam I wrote
Judaism I wrote Catholicism and
Christianity those were the four and um
I ruled out Judaism probably for kind of
um I just didn't make sense that the old
T like I felt like if you believed in
the New Testament you should believe in
the Old Testament
yeah now I'm not like a religious
scholar by any means this was just my
thought process
Islam um at that point I I just kind of
felt
like God like it's weird because I have
a different view now but at the time I
felt like God blessed the
West yeah a lot of yeah and now I'm like
I don't
know want to say that no no not like
that I just like at the time you know I
mean there's lot of propaganda about the
East and I I think God blessed those
that kept marriage between a man and a
woman not a man and three women not a
man and some [__] and that just
didn't like make the three wom thing it
just didn't make sense to me um and so
then that kind of left me Christianity
and Catholicism and I actually I joined
a Christian Church for like two three
years but something yeah but something
was just like off about it and I can't
describe and I couldn't describe why and
when I got into the red pill I finally
figured out why all the wi men were led
by the women but I didn't know it at the
time but just something felt like a not
that's in Catholicism too a lot but less
I was mine's more simple I'm like who's
mad at the gays oh the Catholics I saw
Nick's movement they're the only one
saying F slur and stuff yeah like I
guess I'm a Catholic no no but for me it
was I I felt like okay it didn't make
sense that everybody reads their Bible
and interprets for themselves and
Institute
an ins made more sense to me because I
was like then you get all of these
random churches popping up and they make
a good argument that religion can um be
infiltrated and then institutions get
corrupt and about money so it's a good
argument which that's fine too because
then the meat the meat and potatoes is
still Christian even if they're making a
[__] ton of money you still have a a way
to save the people but if it's just an
atheist tribe and all the money he's
going to corporations now you have two
gray systems the hollow systems imagine
having a Christian system and the ruling
class is taking all the money I mean
think about it the Catholic Church they
say makes so much money that's the
number one charity on Earth yeah they
they can rip us off they're number one
yeah no one's even close they're not
number one by a percent they're number
one by a lot yeah so if they're the
number one charity on Earth yeah they
can scam me I don't give a [__] and and
it just kind of made more I feel like
the Catholics make you do the hard thing
like their church is not entertaining
it's not like you know and and
traditionally it's in Latin and sitting
through a Latin Mass like I think
there's something about silence that
brings you closer to God and I don't do
well with it either obviously I talk a
lot like I noticed every time I'd meet
Orthodox or Protestants they'd have
words for describing gay people so the
Orthodox would be like well we we don't
really buy into that but this this this
or the Protestants would be like it God
loves everyone but the Catholics no
matter how liberal their family was
they'd always say no it's a sin and
that's why growing up I'm like these
guys are the hardcore ones I only
respect these guys and the message of
father son Holy Spirit and Mary this is
teach what is a preaching family that's
a family unit father son Mom that's the
best thing to stitch to your psyche is a
family unit like when I hear Catholic I
hear family when I hear Jesus I hear
family that's all I want to think I
don't when I hear [__] Protestant I
think of rainbows when I think of
Orthodox I think of ineffective
Christians that they're strong
Christians but like worldwide they
didn't accomplish anything they're just
losers and got slaughtered by Catholics
when who got their heads cut off for
Jesus it wasn't the Orthodox it wasn't
the Protestants it was the Catholics
they literally got their heads cut off
to spread Christianity these are the
true Christians but I'm not talking
about modern day Catholic I'm talking
about like up until the 1700s they were
based they're who I want to be and they
are the reason these the Protestant
Reformation and the Orthodox they're the
reason these guys got to breathe but
imagine going imagine meeting God and
saying hey you know that that group of
people who got their heads cut off for
you I ditch them for the Orthodox church
or the Protestant get the [__] out of
here I'm not going to meet God and say I
ditch the guys getting their heads cut
off for you I'm gonna go with them what
the [__] but they're gay now the
vatican's gay now yeah so it's so hard
to defend this [__] is people just point
hey do you believe in the pope and stuff
but you're right even Albert Pike said
uh worship must be taught yeah you
cannot let a child like try and
understand God yeah that's but that's
that's what made the most sense to me so
even when I was like I went to a
Protestant church for like maybe two
three years that's what made me like
pick like kind of go back to Catholic
because that it just didn't make ugly
walls they have ugly walls with no art
like my my first time going in a church
was in Miami yeah I forget is it ghu I
don't know oh my God I'm blanking but
it's like such nice art inside and then
but I was so ashamed I just like put my
hat on and just looked at my feet and
I'm the first one to run out as soon as
it's over because I don't want people
talking to me I don't want someone
saying yo the crazy zeras in church that
that's humiliating like there's people
there with their families and the stuff
I do online is like crazy but I remember
it was at I had a black eye I'm in
church I felt so weird black eyy and a
[__] pocket filled with drugs I'm
kidding but the point is Protestants and
Orthodox get the [__] out of our way
Roman Catholics in the house and we
don't even have a chance do we women are
[__] and not even the church can save
them according to you um it's over
you're saying you're the end times lady
you got a big sign they're all whes I
don't I mean I think it's unlikely as a
society we go back um I do see you
know no I can't even lie I just don't
see any I you know I think with God
anything's possible miracles happen but
but I said this on a podcast that was
blasphemy a lot of people got mad I said
I have more faith in women being [__]
than I do in Jesus I've never received
so much hate mail for saying that but I
meant it because I Str everyone
struggles with faith in God that's what
it is that's what it means to have faith
but I'm certain women are becoming the
worst whes like if they close we're 20
times more men are 20 times more horny
than women but women close the gap on
cheating for the first time in thousands
of years that means that they are
there's I thought in ancient times on
Pagan Temple steps those Jezebels and
hookers those hookers are clean compared
to modern day women today hookers got i'
[__] Less in ancient times hookers cuz
they'd be assigned to one man that means
modern day women get [__] more than
ancient hookers yeah that's traumatizing
and if they close the gap it has to be
end times because everything is
sexuality so if they actually close the
gap on cheating when they're 20 times
less
incentivized that's disgusting these
people are actually not women anymore
like what is going on and you know why I
get to talk
I lost my virginity at 21 like a month
before I turned 21 so that's why people
are like oh that's where all that
[__] high and mighty talk comes from
and it's not like no women wanted me I
had trouble getting women but I could
have done the job but in my head I was
like yo sex is not a handshake like my
friends are having sex like it's a
handshake I was like no no there's
something deeper there now it's a
handshake it's an times who gives a [__]
no don't sin cuz that's I remember when
I first understood sin I was 24 years
old as a bouncer and I broke one girl's
heart I've never seen a [__] spiral and
become a [__] she
destroyed 100 men in my city and that
everyone would blame me they're like oh
he broke her first she was a good girl
and I was like whoa you break one [__]
she breaks a hundred dudes and aund
dudes turn into criminals and Destroy
Society from one sexual act
yikes that's don't have sex you ow them
like apology letters yeah yeah I
remember I once ruined a 20 year
friendship between two girls 20 years
wow because I had sex with the other one
after that one and then uh gez that was
like the most guilt I've ever felt
because 20 years means they they had
Facebook photos of them in kindergarten
together and then that's when I was like
oh women can't be around each other you
know yeah I lost a 20-year friendship
doing that yes what do you mean yeah it
was um a girl I like um I was like a
bridesmaid in our wedding we're friends
for like 20 years and yeah I did a show
about how women shouldn't get fat after
getting married and she gained a lot of
weight and then she she kind of took it
personal and she just wanted me to lie
to her and I wouldn't um yeah like I I
wasn't even talking about her yeah and
then she just said stop being my friend
and I was like okay then yeah that was
it horrible that is horrible yeah yeah
it was really sad um I thought yeah I
thought we were friends and then I don't
think I've ever done that like when my
buddies change when my buddies change
their ideologies I don't really attack
them unless they have a huge platform
and they're weakening Jesus like sneo
that's why we started beefing he's like
attack Jesus I want biblical War mode on
him on Twitter but like yeah every time
my buddies change ideologies I've always
been the guy to
like pretend it doesn't bother me and
then I realized damn this guy's just
turning into a liberal like just cut
them out as soon as you sense your
buddies are going blue pill or your
friends are going blue pill you keep
them around there'll be an allegation
against you Pearl's a bad boss or this
well oh God I God I dealt with that
whole thing but no even um no with her
she um she's an abusive boss no Pearl's
an abusive boss that's what they always
say right as soon as they defect they
say yeah I was being abused there's a
pearl has a whip and blah blah blah yeah
yeah they'll say like slave contracts
you know why you deserve it because you
appeasing liberal mindset you were
trying to win over a
liberal talking about like as soon as
one of your friends turned blue pill and
yeah yeah cuz with her I knew she was
super liberal so I would just avoid
certain topics but why was she around
you cuz you were trying to appease her
just like me trying to PE one buddy we
try and win them over dude they're
animals leave them alone because because
you you like them as people a lot of the
time outside of that you know yeah but
they eventually bite you there's no
point Have you ever yeah no that's
you're right I've I've been snaked by
red pill people but it's not 100% of the
time I can't remember one blue pill
person in my life that didn't snake me
this a 100% success rate that they turn
they because it's anxiety like oh co
Zero's not wearing a mask turn on him
but there's a bunch of red people in my
life that I've mingled with them and
they never did anything to me so I'm
like wow this zone is so much more free
blo pill people and I deserved it all me
trying to be friends with those people
what's crazy is yeah I was really I was
really I was really sad too I was so sad
well that comes from narcissism I can
win over the moderate or the liberal no
[__] him let him burn leave them in dust
because they are going to turn on you as
soon as there's a Calon cold on TV
they're going to turn you yeah well
that's what um that actually happened
even when I had Nick on I had everyone
like ever it was it was so I did not
because with Nick I knew he was
controversial but I I did not anticipate
like the
nuke the nuke I did not I'll tell you if
I have one regret it was ever taking
down that interview initially like that
was my one what what was the
consequences if you didn't take it down
weren't you g to get like deleted it was
on Rumble I just like deleted it because
I was going viral for like the wrong
reasons and it was just like I just
didn't want to deal with it so I took it
down and I gave Nick a really fair
interview and I think people were mad at
me for that because yeah no Nick I mean
I have nothing bad to say about him um
but now he's a nuke like I'm like ready
to collaborate he's like yes you should
know this I'm like I know you're about
to Nuke me one collaboration I lost my
whole 11 th000 people Discord server
30,000 a month demonetization one
collaboration like every time you're
around Nick I had I had multiple friends
like come out and then give me like
racist allegations or some oh for the
Nick thing yeah yeah it was like a guy I
co-hosted with for a year called me col
and I like it was so cra so hard to say
Nick's not a racist because he'll be on
his show and be like yeah I am you know
everyone knows he's not but on his show
he says he is just to piss them and
that's what happened like I had um one
girl kind of like came at like she was
coming at him and so he was kind of
making yeah and so then I got all the
heat because I didn't like tell Nick off
or something what did you say something
about I'm Italian Tim yeah well he Nick
was like making fun of her because she
had she was dating like interracially
basically um and you could tell he was
kidding clearly but they take a clip
they don't you know and it's like OB
well he does believe that races should
stick together yeah no I know I even
believe that now just because the
success rate I noticed that like people
the stats yeah are better if people date
that's what Nick Nick although although
all of his um all of his freaking God
they're always like they always go Cole
burner Cole burner to me to me um yeah
no cuz my ex-boyfriend was black and so
they'll just be like it's like you date
like a black guy or something they just
call and oh the Cole is turning oh okay
it's like a racist thing
for me the first time they ever turned
on me is when uh I said yes I don't
believe in race mixing but I zerka I'm
still dating I'm still I'm still going
to date this Latina I'm still only
dating these Latino girls around me and
then they got all angry at me and then
I'm like dude if all women are [__]
it's not a big deal right now they're
all [__] anyway what the [__] are you
talking about but I understand I don't
know I never even like cared like one
way or another but it's just like I
think there's outliers but like think
think of Chinese women yeah they belong
with Chinese men that's where they no I
think they date interracially the most
Chinese what I think I was looking at
these stats the other day I I think
white people interracially date the
least is that true I I think so don't
quote me on it oh yeah like a white
neighborhood everyone it's like white on
white love yeah oh yeah Chinese really
they're but it's white guys it's not no
it's the the women I think at but
they're not with Mexicans they're not
with black guys they're just with white
guys these probably probably why Master
race is that why no I don't know I don't
know but here's the thing though I
really think a Chinese man will
understand a Chinese woman the best yeah
maybe that's a cultural thing I don't
know yeah but I I give a [__] about that
if I can make it law I would make it are
you guys degenerates or Christians
together that's how i' make it if you
guys are a good Christian couple I don't
give a [__] about by your colors but if
you guys are just partying and doing
[__] cocaine in a [__] apartment
then no you can't be with that other
that's something in college it's all
mixed to race people having sex that's
where it stems from it's just
evil I'm kidding holy [__] like wow like
is this another Nick please God no no
God he's Mexicans are [__] these
white women no I don't think Mexicans
should [__] white women because they're
I think white women are now the largest
skanks right the they are the most
liberated so they have the highest skank
energy well if you look at STD rates
that's not true but
really no STD rates it black women is
one then second is Hispanic then third
is white and then fourth is Asian Asians
are and it's interesting because these
stats like um the STD stats they are the
same even when people migrate from other
countries so when Asians come to America
they still the lowest yeah same with um
yeah wow so like when Asians come to
America they still have the lowest STD
rates I thought it' be different bra
although Brazilians kind of [__] it up a
little bit they're like they're like one
of the
highest oh really yeah yeah all sorts of
colors there in Brazil yeah well some
people argue it's because of like
healthc care that sort of thing but I
don't know I think women can lie about
body count but STDs don't lie I thought
it would be the white women because
they're the most free free means [__]
well in Eastern Europe they get a lot of
abortions so like white women
seem no but then in the US I don't know
I I couldn't tell you but yeah but I
just I was not expecting that that to
get as crazy as it did black women had
the highest CDs and then Hispanic women
Mexican women does it
say um if if I remember correctly that's
it was they were second white women
third and then but I do think I I know
basically when I looked at up from a
world scale it was like Japanese women
were the least promiscuous but they're
very career oriented their their
childless rate is pretty high Eastern
European women have similar um birth
rates to America but I think their
abortion rate is slightly above average
Africa they have the highest birth rate
but the highest STD rate um and then
in uh the US it's like somewhere in
between damn cuz the US it's like one
point I always wonder if those Japanese
women are focused on career and not
getting married like you said wouldn't
that why why don't they morph into Boss
[__] independent male mind I don't know
I don't but they're they're sexist like
they're just not having sex because
they're very conservative Nation that's
what's holding them back yeah I I don't
know I I don't know much about Japan in
general so I don't know I just know I
just look at their birth rate stats
which are really low like I think it's
like 0 five kids there or maybe one
they're like one of the low same with
South Korea and I know their STD rates
are low their abortion rates are low to
me what shocked me when I lived in Japan
is it was normal for husbands and wives
to cheat on each other as a casual thing
that they talk about openly not in
between each other but the women will be
in a room with other guys and they'll
cheat and it's like a date and then she
goes back to her husband they cheat so
much in Japan yes or I was around the
wrong people maybe but these women were
having 20 30 shots in 10 minutes of
alcohol I've never seen people drink
like that like drinking more than the
men and they have a serious problem with
drinking in Japan like now I know a
nation without drugs becomes alcoholic
as [__] they are alcoholics they're like
laying down on subway trains in the
morning time and I have a bunch of
photos with them I had a blast CU like
we were having fun but Americans don't
drink like that they drink so much and
they live in shoe boxes like the
smallest in Japan yeah
yeah but they they seemed a lot happier
but they have the highest suicide rate
yeah they do why I don't know every
morning the train would be late because
someone jumped in front of it I was like
what the [__] I think maybe it's like
work culture I know they're really hard
workers there no I think it's because
they don't have religion like they got
Shinto Buddhism ripped from them and the
last Samurai was a [__] white guy Tom
Cruz and it's like they have nothing
they have nothing to be morally bound to
or spiritually I mean think of Japan
with uh with the cross can't I can't see
them being that deep in despair but
they're like very atheist they have
nothing what the [__] do they have
technology yeah and America just kind of
let's be honest Japan is just an
American colony since World War II they
don't have Where is the Japanese culture
cuz [__] made cafes is not Japanese
culture there's no Samurai there's none
of their cult they're all disconnected
from their history lineage
spirituality so wow us knows how to
conquer a place and now it's just Co
Coca-Cola commercials and all that [__]
right same with the German people after
World War II like what are they now go
to Germany and they're they have like
events about having sex with dogs have
you seen that like M they want to marry
dogs they're super liberal and and like
every I was raised by German nannies you
know like well I don't want to say that
the Germans were more based in the past
that's not what I'm saying but I'm
saying like look at these nations who
beef with the US and look at their
people after like the people are little
[__] like they are completely like
the Japanese are just weak now and Ryan
Dawson was making the argument that
they're strong and proud no they're not
he's a liar he knows it's not true what
he's saying they're not a proud people
people they don't know anything about
their one Emperor nothing they don't
know any of their history and humans can
only be strong if they're connected to
their history that's why every time
there's a war Afghanistan Iraq they hit
up all the [__] museums and wipe away
the history first yeah they have to
disconnect you from that's why they
disconnect us from the Bible right they
give us like Ancient
Aliens yeah because I've never it's
interesting because before I started
doing podcasting I never really thought
about too much like I don't it's been
interesting learning like I've started
learning about my family history and
stuff and it's actually kind of
interesting yeah yeah no my grandpa was
a baker you can I make good cookies so
you don't no cookie jokes here Doan Nick
fant's cookie joke what's I don't know
what that is they're going to link you
to that I make I make banana bread too I
don't know if that you cannot go through
the process of self- individuation
without looking your history timeline
family tree all that Carl Young talks
about this he like this is
why people are so confused in their
early 20s you know they don't bother to
look into it and then they look into it
later but no what keeps you strong is
your ancestral ties like everyone should
look into that well I think the girls
are here what the [__] yeah
already you hear them what do you mean
they're here no a blessing gave me a
sign earlier let's go wait how how many
girls how many girls are here I can have
a
cigarette okay yeah the women are here
so we got to go throw drinks on me and
[__] are those kind of women or what
kind of women I don't know I just have
to play by year yeah so so let the
people know where they can find you
twitter.com zerk official John zerk on
YouTube and you can find
me bathing in the holy spirit because
Jesus is God literally God everyone's
God not my savior
everyone watching Jesus is your god at
one point in history all everyone on
Earth was a Christian that was the
happiest time in history but they called
it the Dark Ages because you're a stupid
[__] check it out Jesus Is God this is
the only God story with sacrifice can
you imagine is there any higher sense of
love than taking a bullet for a loved
one that's Jesus story if your God
didn't sacrifice himself for you that's
a
demon Jesus is
[Music]
king um thanks for coming cira we should
do it again sometime um I wish we had a
little more time but we we hit
everything though yeah yeah we did all
right guys like the video on your way
out subscribe to the channel ring that
notification Bell and I'll talk to you
next
time